ولم يضيف يعني انا
من الذين بقيوا ولم يغادروا ان من الذين
بقوا
غادرت لمده سبعه اشهر نتيجه صرف شخصي عام
وعدت مع مطلع 2013
لكن ما مر به الوطن لا شك ان هو موجع
اثاره في الالم عندما يمر وطن تعشق وتحبه
بهكذا امتحان عسير لا مجال الان للخوض
باسبابه انما انا احكي الان عن تداعيات
بعد عشر سنوات من اقصى السنوات التي يمكن
ان تمر بها الاوطان اكيد راح يترك بداخلك
بدوب غائره اكيد راح يرمي على روحك غلالي
من الحزن
وان تشعر بان هذا الوطن الذي كان يوما ما
شابا لماذا تحول من وطن ياسمين في هذه
السنوات الى وطن الرصاص اسئله كثيره اصابه
جيلنا افجعتنا
اوجعتنا لكننا حاولنا دائما ان نستمر ان
ندافع همم يعني همم نحفز ارواحنا من اجل
الاستمرار لانه مسؤولياتنا كعاملين في
الشان العام هي مسؤوليات كبيره هذه هي
الارتدادات الرئيسيه اللي مرينا فيها في
هذه السنوات السابقه واللي لا اخفيك يعني
ولا اخفي على الاخوه المشاهدين انها تركت
في قلبي حقيقه ندوب غائره يعني